[Music]
on Twitter recently you got some
attention you were mentioning that you
analyze your own dreams that you are in
and I have trouble even remembering my
dreams I don't usually remember them but
you make a point of like writing them
down a minute you wake up I did not
always just like ones that are very
specific or recurring or like I think
might relate to stress or anxiety
perhaps like what's an example of an
anxiety dream you've had an example that
happens a lot is is you're in a city and
where's this you're in a safe
environment here where you're Frank it's
just us this is like a therapy so my
anxiety dreams tend to always relate to
you for care and so I'll be like on
stage getting ready to act and I'm just
in my underwear and I look down and it's
just like I think might as well be like
an old man's beard or something or I'll
be topless and it'll be like up like
coming up here first hairy chest right
right it so you you could like make a
topiary is what you're saying like it
could if the Treasure Trail was a super
high yeah so what does that mean I have
no idea I don't know what that means
that was the highest pitch response yeah
dogs all over the country like huh no
you don't know you don't know what that
what that means I have so bizarre I mean
usually they say if you there's a
correlation yeah you know what my wife's
mother will know because she has pubic
hair dream soon
yeah I might as well talk about it right
here right now yeah I mean it's crazy
with her no she actually is always if I
have a dream she'll say that's because
you fear falling into a well yeah which
I fear you also tweeted about a Justin
Bieber dream yes this dream with Justin
Bieber we were in his like childhood
home in Canada just hanging out and his
mom came home with takeout from Ikea and
we were like yeah these are your dreams
are so specific
most people they talk about their dream
is that side go to school but then I'm
running but a monster and I can't get
away
yours are I can't take out yeah I can't
Justin Bieber's home in Canada yeah and
you're excited yeah
oh we were stoked we were like yes our
favorite alright she's probably getting
paid by IKEA yeah I love it too yeah
they're trying to recover from that what
was it horse meatballs or something yeah
please gosh man sponsor on the show they
are response on this show a silly woman
you're insane that never happened thumbs
up
that stuff's easy to assemble this is
like here right here but this is horse
meat
have you met Justin Bieber by the way no
never no I mean I asked you for a reason
there's a web site that gets people that
look alike in photographs together yeah
have you seen this one this is you how
long ago I was I think a seventeen or
eighteen seventeen maybe that's pretty
stunning actually yeah you're like which
ones which